this is the machine that court reporters
use in a courtroom to type out
everything that is said in the courtroom
it is currently plugged into my laptop
so basically everything that i type
goes in here and gets translated this is
the initial side of the keyboard so it's
like starting letters
these are vowels and this is the final
side so like finishing letters
and this is an asterisk when i put in an
asterisk it deletes the word that was
above it to type on it you have to push
down the keys at the same time so i'm
going to spell
the word girl
so that spells girl so it went in there
and then it translated it to girl if i
wanted to spell the word zoo for
instance i'd push these down at the same
time and it translates in here
to zoo long story short it just takes
too long
stenographers push down multiple keys at
the same time to spell one word with
each stroke
so this was just me key smashing that
was six strokes so that would be six
words so stenographers can write 225
words a minute
so when there's multiple people talking
in court they can keep up with that too
so now i have to ask how many words per
minute can you type
today i'm going to show you guys what
letter corresponds to each key
so this is the initial side this key is
s
t p h and this is also
s k w r
these four keys are the vowels the
vowels they have are
a o e and u so this is the final side of
the keyboard
this is f p l t
d r b g
s z this whole middle key here is an
asterisk
you may have noticed that this doesn't
include every letter in the alphabet
to get every letter in the alphabet we
have to use a combination of keys
a b c d e
f g h i
j k l m
n o p q
r s t u
v w x y
and z you can't do the full alphabet
with the final side of the keyboard but
you can do
b d f g j k
l m n p r s
t v x zed
here is a visual representation long
story short no
and here's why court reporters can
indicate between speakers they can read
back what was just said and they can
also understand accents pretty well
software available to us right now just
isn't close enough to being 100 accurate
in a court of law
like think about all the times syria's
misheard you there isn't much room for
error in a court
also imagine if there was a loud sneeze
or cough in the courtroom
this could mess up any software or audio
recording you have
whereas a court reporter isn't confused
about who's speaking and what a cough is
also having everything typed out versus
an audio or a video recording
makes it easier for anyone to go back
and reference the transcript
almost immediately there are also other
uses for stenography
real-time captioning is needed for
people who are hard of hearing or deaf
also captioning for movies shows
anything one minute isn't nearly enough
time to explain this and i'm still a
student so i'm still learning too
if i forgot to add something important
please comment and educate me